what you know about the pins
bro I have a feeling this is GNA
slap slap
[Music]
it burner boy here doing snack Wars UK
versus Nigeria for lad Bible close your
eyes for a minute we're going to put the
food down don't bring no fish and chips
man you're going to wish you had fish
and chips I
reckon
[Music]
so that there's no way this is that
microwave lasagna thing oh no it's worse
that's uh cauliflower
Cheese look that gets me going I'm
hungry y
cauliflower can we skip
this eat the whole thing fam you take me
hospital
after
you're a big fan of jolif fries yeah
most definitely yeah I would eat this I
I would not eat that what in if I told
you I would probably be the best cook
cook in the world all I know is that
there's rice and there's things that
make it
red so that's like your your seventh bit
of jolof rice but you haven't tried the
colif cheese no no no I have in my
mind and how does it taste in your mind
Terri
terrible terrible this one already so
you're not going to touch it no no no no
no no no fair enough I've never seen
fear in a man's eyes like that honestly
terrified okay but this is a mad combo
though chicken and mushroom chicken and
mushrooms like it's the it's like it's
all right you know have you had pot
noodles before of course oh great yeah
but it's like for me I put my little
sauce in it I don't just get the way to
sell it to me go pretty your own flavor
in
it and this is Tesco's
flavor a little bit of s would have made
it at least stand a
chance going in for seconds though for
sure don't get twisted this has save my
life you hear
me so I can't knock
it now talk us through this one well
this is this is Gary that's like um
casava in English and this is a Goosey I
don't know the English English
for I don't think there's an English
translation but yeah I've heard some
white people call it spinach for some
reason it does not look like the stuff
papey take so I don't know where you get
spinach but yeah it could
be cuz you do actually kind of feel like
papey after you eat it Soo
oh sh we have the next one don't we I I
I was just watching you I was quite
enjoying it hey you know I haven't even
eaten all day you know so you can't do
this there's some cauliflower cheese
over there if you want it I think I know
this one but who wins out the two of
them Hey Hey Hey Hey Hey listen
what you know about the pins
bro this was my sh like we would mix
would just mix anything with it like
what is
this well I thought that was pins oh is
it yeah what yeah oh it's a mix all
right I have a feeling this is going to
slap I'm telling you I feel
it
slap
it yeah this is what I'm going to be
drinking with my
meal after this um
situation this
origin you know what I feel like I
stopped liking this because I had too
much of it and now I see it and I want
to just throw
up so you going back for seconds of the
pins yes please we'll stick with the
pins pims will not let you down you know
what about with a bit of
origin see you take things too far
man H okay what the f what this two
black biscuits
what so that is black pudding which is
congealed Pig's
blood Pig's blood
yeah so now it's not even just swine
it's the blood
congealed what is wrong with you
guys I get it yeah oh please try it
please hell no you just told me it was
Pig's blood it's nice
congealed this I'll eat the whole plate
just to comp compliment for not eating
this Pig's
blood it's cold the black pudding might
be
warm all right just no no carry on with
that this called I'm be there's cooked
cow foot in there yeah but we won't
touch the pig's blood no no okay worth a
shot this one
wins all way long do you want to try
another dish all right can we keep this
for me please to wash my mouth from all
the
tragedy this I don't recall ever seeing
them well I love you oh thanks
mate first love all right we've only
just
met is this sour or sweet or I I don't
understand what I'm tasting that's the
mystery of a love heart no one knows oh
right not that good no cuz I'm trying to
I have to try
this are we going to get a point you
know what I feel like they serve
different purposes which of the two
sweets can you propose with obviously
this cuz it's the mess I've got more
purposes fair enough so yeah this wins
then based off of that it's definitely
go on more purposes just to warn you
this one's two cauliflower
cheese you got to eat the whole plate
before you go we ran it past your
manager they said that was
fine okay I'll survive
you almost got me there you know but why
would you put this against you guys just
want to lose what is a space reader bro
it's crisp of some sort but it's like no
matter how great crisp is you can't put
it against plantain bro even if there
was gold inside you can't as long as
it's in a crisp bag plantain wins but
you know I'll try it oh it's got alien
faces as well
that's cute that's very
cute
no just no it's cute but it doesn't
taste
cute plantain wins this round
so yeah can I have my stuff back
please Nigeria
one you say this is the best interview
you've done then hands
down well I think we're just going to
leave now you can carry on eating that
then peace
peace see you guys in the next interview
or say or I'll interview the next person
or
whatever black came hungry man right
try Tim I'm not eating no Tim try Tim T
Tiffany try to Tim Tim try to Tim
Tim try to know try to Tim Tim